well if we were economically stable I
think it would be that we would be able
to co-exist even with things like this
weird like killing killing people and
and changing children's gender but in
economic instability that's that's when
people are more willing to take the law
into their own hands if they're
suffering if they're starving if their
families have threat of death then I
mean what choice do you have your
government's failed you at that point
um which again pisses me off that Biden
hasn't talked about the Federal Reserve
since he's been in office and why we're
going to bankrupt as a country I know I
need him the state so you're talking
earlier about the domestic State of the
Union this is all like domestic stuff
now internationally the state of the
union is the liberal economic order is
turning into the new world order at
least this is my ideal thing uh like
what's happening is a new world order is
being created whether or not it's bricks
which is the Chinese Russian India
Brazil and uh South Africa South African
Coalition or if it's the liberal World
Order which is like England France
Germany United States it's